hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today i'm
gonna be reviewing
big old freak by megan the stallion
before i start
do not forget to subscribe please
subscribe
i am trying to move out of my parents
house
and therefore i need you guys to
subscribe also
comment did i get it right did i get it
wrong and
comment what video should i do next week
i'ma start the video
i'm excited okay
[Music]
[Music]
she said something that i think's like
super important
so she was saying she's got a big butt
you know we
we appreciate a thick woman okay and
second she said she's gonna make him
wait
she wants to take her relationship slow
i think that's good good for her
feet on the bed i [ __ ] him up in the
head suck it then look in his eyes
then the next day i might leave him on
red pop it
okay so she is playing some games here
she said okay she's gonna do some sexual
favors for him
and then the next day leave him on bread
i don't know why she would want to do
that because that seems kind of mean
like leave him on red for what but okay
[Music]
he hit my phone with a horse so i know
let me come
[Music]
this is a little bit of mixed messaging
because she started the song saying
i'm gonna make him wait but then like
two lyrics later
she's seeing that she's riding the like
she she's riding some stuff so
there's some mixed messaging here
honestly i'm going to continue she looks
very pretty in the music video
she pulls off the red hair and not not
many people can in my opinion
when i'm ready to go hey i had a couple
of shots at the bar i'm finna play with
that dick in the car i got them swerving
okay so this sounds like she's in um
kind of like a secret relationship
because
she doesn't show up to the party with
him but she'll leave with him and then
like kind of you know do some stuff
later
so i guess she can do that i don't think
that's the healthiest relationship but
like if that's what you want to do go
ahead
gotta funny tip tip toes and roll to the
tip like me hey i gotta
[Music]
don't know what to do without it
she's just kind of saying that she's
good at having sex
as a woman like if i was to write a song
i probably wouldn't
make that the main thing like i would
say about myself
i'm not shaming her at all she's totally
welcome
to do that so she's saying i am good at
having sex
[Music]
[Music]
she's saying that she has something that
he
needs and she said it has nothing to do
with her body i found that a little hard
to believe just watching the video
like honestly like she's pretty slim
thick she has a nicer ass than me she's
saying it's nothing to do with her body
i think it's a little bit to do with her
but i'm just being honest
[ __ ] they love me cause i'm cold
you can't take
[Music]
listen i bet he gonna like it he won't
okay so she's just kind of saying that
the boys
really like her and like she's got like
mind control like you gotta tell me what
that's like because
i have never been able to control a man
like not like that
and then she's just again going back to
the main theme of the song
i am good at having sex that's the theme
that's the theme of the song ain't
nobody freaked like me
get what you
[Applause]
[Music]
let me rub
[Music]
again like she's not really saying
anything new like all she's saying
is i am good at having sex are you good
at anything else like are you smart
it's not that like you can't include
that in the song but if i were to write
a song
i'd maybe say like i'm good at that you
know and
i'm smart and funny but she's just
really
advertising the one thing and the mind
control thing so i'll continue i mean
she looks great don't get me wrong like
she looks very pretty and like i i like
like what she's doing in the video like
she looks pretty
lately i got what you need i'm gonna
give it to you baby
going crazy crazy feeding it for me
lately
i got what you need imma give you
another observation i have so i learned
about gangs recently and that when i was
watching the other videos like
that like i was watching gangs that's
why everyone had so many friends
good to know but now i'm watching megan
the stallion
also have a lot of friends that are just
in like stripper costumes basically like
if
i got my group of friends you know and i
said
do you guys want to like dress half
naked pump the air
and film it they would probably say
absolutely not
but apparently we have different friend
groups that's something they like to do
i'm really just like pointing out my
observations
[Music]
hello
[Music]
okay this there isn't much in this part
it's just a lot of like
shaking the booty you know twerking the
butt a little bit
and honestly like putting her mouth open
and like a sexual weight like i don't
think if i did that i would pull that
off like i would look kind of weird but
she's just like
putting her up hey hey
just interesting oh now she's
like i just don't think that me like
like like i just don't think it's the
same effect i'm not even gonna lie but
the way she does it it looks pretty cool
like i kind of wanna like
you know be in her friend group a little
bit
very nice like hair very good bod okay
so
honest review of the song like it would
be a good like
sex song because that's literally all
she talks about is i'm good at sex
it just wasn't my favorite what i would
like to see is like i'm good at sex i'm
smart
i'm funny and i'm a really nice person
to be around but she's just advertising
one thing and then controlling men
that doesn't seem like very nice you
know it's it was
it was an okb i thought she looked
gorgeous like she looked very pretty
obviously she's a good twerker like i'd
like to take some lessons you know
that's going to conclude my review don't
forget subscribe
subscribe subscribe so i can move out of
my parents house it would be great
comment below did i get it right did i
get it wrong do you agree with me or do
you disagree
and comment what song i should do next
the most liked song
on this video i will do next i'll talk
to you guys later bye